all right um this is from msnbc it says
representative marjorie taylor green
introduced a bill in congress on friday
that would ban gender affirming care for
transgender minors across the country
gender farming care also known as
mutilation and sterilization of children
it's the most sweeping and draconian
piece of legislation conjured by an ever
more radicalized and violent anti-trans
movement
literally no examples of violence are
provided ever
a violent movement but
not not one example of violence
not they can't provide one example of a
quote anti-trans person
acting out violently against trans
people not one example can't do it
doesn't exist
um
i'll tell you one thing you can find
examples in the reverse
while the bill sports only 14 republican
co-sponsors its passage would likely
become a priority if the gop were to
retake congress this fall
that's another another humiliating
statement about the republican party
that only has 14 co-sponsors i mean the
marjorie taylor green bill
um and it doesn't matter how you feel
about marjorie taylor greene personally
it makes no difference
um she
this bill every single republican in
congress should support it we should
demand that they all support it the bill
is very simple and it's exactly what the
federal government needs to do it is
exactly what we need republicans in dc
to be doing or trying to do
it would simply ban
doctors from castrating or mutilating
kids
period that's it you can't do it
um
it continues since the 2020 presidential
election reactionary forces in the u.s
have increasingly become more focused uh
on trans issues physicians and staff
members at
boston children's hospitals were
threatened last week by a far-right
gender-critical internet mob that spread
lies about the facilities work with
transgender adolescents
the harassment campaign was kicked off
by shia reichik who runs the anti-lgbtq
social media account libs of tick tock
along with anti-abortion and anti-lgbtq
media personality matt walsh
both told the lie that the hospital was
performing hysterectomies on children
well that that in and of itself is a lie
because that's actually not what i said
let me ask you something what if there
was uh someone out there who kept a log
of every single thing you did every
minute of the day i bet you'd be pretty
displeased with that well what if i told
you that's exactly what happens every
time you go online your internet
provider like at your comcast is allowed
to store logs of every website you've
ever visited
and they can legally sell this data to
anyone that's why i always use
expressvpn expressvpn reroute your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your internet provider can't
see or log what you do online
now many of you might be wondering well
if i'm routing all my data through a vpn
doesn't mean that the vpn can see what
i'm doing and log my data instead
and you're very astute you're right to
think that way many vpns claim to have a
no logs policy but they've got logs all
over the place expressvpn that's not the
case they've got no logs at all it's a
no law guarantee and you don't take my
word for it expressvpn or or their word
for it actually expressvpn is so
confident in their no logs claim they
even had one of the biggest assurance
firms audit their technology and they
confirmed yep no logs stop letting
people keep logs of what you do online
visit expressvpn.com matt walsh right
now and find out how you can get three
months free um i didn't say that the
hospital is performing
is is definitely performing quote
unquote gender affirming hysterectomies
on children
there's certainly evidence that they
have
reason to think that they have but what
i actually said is
it's almost irrelevant because we know
they're doing it to 18 year olds which
is still horrifying
and by the way if an 18 year old is not
uh mentally competent
to sign on the dotted line for a college
loan and is so incompetent that we have
to forgive those loans after the fact
that merely that merely you know
presenting the option to an 18 year old
is a is a a scam
well if that's the case then what but an
18 year old is has the mental faculties
necessary
to agree to get a hysterectomy
for cosmetic reasons
well that makes no sense but what i
actually said is that that's what i said
even if it's at 18 it's still horrifying
and
besides
whether or not they're doing this
particular mutilation procedure on kids
whether or not they're doing that we
know
that they're performing cosmetic double
mastectomies on kids we know that they
are chemically castrating kids
we know that so that's what i said
so in accusing me of lying of course
msnbc is lying not not that they care
there are any standards here at all
um we did send them something you know
saying they need to retract this but uh
there's just
already for the media there's we know
that there's very little accountability
and when it comes to anything in the
trans world
as we've seen they just they have full
license to just say anything they want
to say it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how
far-fetched it is makes no difference
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really is that's what
it is we're joy we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
uh this video to stay up to date with
all my content and if you want even more
you can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang